mais oui oui oui un talon oui ah oui oui
a pris ah oui à temps
oui ah oui oui à pee wee quoi papa fafpa
vous n'êtes pas capable d'attraper une
brique avec vos mains non six patrons
alors quoi mais oui mais moi moi en plus
attraper au travail ce n'est pas une
région petit bonhomme mais c'est parce
qu'en plus attraper les bruits jamais
d'eux dans un seau pendent le saut au
grand chez tirer sans l'apport
volontaire saut avec les briques à
chaque fois et alors alors je mets l'eau
dans le seau j'attrape la grande et
riche
j'ai le temps je parle ce crochet
j'attrape la d héroïque j'ai le temps
c'est quand je tire la corde
pas du tout alors je ne vois pas du tout
où je continue à tenir la corde pendant
tout le saut j'attrape la veille dans le
ventre rouge à chacun en prendra plus la
brique et je sois sangsues pied car
entre riches c'est parce que vous n'êtes
pas aussi pendre alors je vous montrais
ce pas difficile
poussez-vous premier temps dans mon
logement boulot dans mon sens blue blue
à première brique génération c'est vous
parce que vous allez en prendre un
deuxième temps j'accroche morceaux au
crochet hop il deuxième ris ne bougeons
pas attention je tient la corde
alors on tient la corde en cas d'accord
la falaise hervé temps d'accord échouer
oh no oh oui alors dites moi comment on
fait pour faire descendre le sauve à ce
qu'une brique acte où tout est là